SERGEI SOKOLENKO: Hello, and
welcome to Real-Time AI--
Bringing Together Dataflow,
TensorFlow Extended,
and Cloud AI.
My name is Sergei Sokolenko,
and I'm a Product Manager
in the Google Cloud.
I wanted to start with
a motivating example.
Recently worked with a
public safety agency which
processes tons of gigabytes
of security logs per day,
but then only a few
thousand of these logs
are of high importance to them.
The current processes
for analysis and finding
these important logs were
based on heuristics and manual
interactions, which
couldn't scale
to the growing volume of logs.
So this agency
engaged with Google
to process large scale
data sets and wanted
to build a unsupervised solution
to identify logs, review
them, and label them.
In another example, we worked
with a national telecom,
which carries the critical
mobile traffic for our nation.
This telecom needed to address
security, vulnerability,
among other threats.
And their current
techniques, which
were based on traditional
signature-based patterns,
were insufficient.
They just couldn't be
updated fast enough.
So this telecom wanted to
analyze sender and receiver
traffic and find anomalies in
the traffic and act on them.
The common factors
to these examples--
what is common to
them is that there
is a large number of events that
is produced by a global user
base, which creates billions
and billions of interactions
when they use these systems.
Another important common
characteristic, a factor,
is that our customers
want to react
to these events with
near-human intelligence
and apply a higher
intelligence than just counting
numbers or creating and
calculating statistics.
And lastly, our
users want to react
to events in near real-time.
This is best visualized
by the following graphic.
Businesses realize the
highest value from events
when they act within
a tight time window
after the event creation.
Another opportunity to
extract value from events
is by storing these streaming
events in data warehouses
and doing analytics on them.
In between, there isn't
much value to extract,
because data is stale or is
difficult to access and not
in a data warehouse, which means
it's not readily available.
Across our customers, we see
two types of common needs--
recommendations and anomaly
and pattern detection.
Recommendations are about
analyzing customer market
signals to present compelling
offers and customized content.
For example, in the
retail industry,
you could create up-sell
offers for your carts.
In the media industry, you could
select the next video or song
to show to a customer.
In the financial industry, you
could suggest a new insurance
offer.
And in the telecom
industry, you could
create a hardware offer or a
service up-sell or cross-sell.
For anomalies and
pattern detection,
here is what
customers want to do,
is examining streams of data
to identify data points which
are outside of the norm.
Now in the financial
industry, for example, you
could detect insider trading.
In retail, you could find
account theft or credit card
fraud.
In the cybersecurity
industry, as we've
seen in our motivating
example, you
could do a denial-of-service
attack prevention.
And in healthcare, you
could do patient monitoring.
And so if we want to
take these use cases
and if we want to act on them
to drive behavior, and not
just act and discover things
after the fact, when it's
too late, we need to use
machine learning and streaming
analytics technologies.
And this is what
real-time AI is about.
It's the difference between
preventing fraud and just
discovering fraud.
It's the difference
between driving more sales
in shopping carts versus seeing
carts being abandoned when
customers move away from them.
Machine learning, together
with streaming analytics
and a global event network,
allows us to do real-time AI.
The Google Cloud offers
a comprehensive set
of tools for model
training and inference.
Big data, for
example, allows you
to do a model training
and predictions right
inside of your data warehouse.
Outside of BigQuery, GCP has the
Google Cloud Platform, Cloud AI
Platform, and
TensorFlow Extended.
Cloud AI Platform offers
training, inference,
and many specialized
services for video, image,
text processing, and other
types of unstructured data
processing.
TensorFlow Extended
is a platform
for production use
of machine learning,
and it's centered
around TensorFlow,
but is available not
just on the Google Cloud.
What is common to all these
machine learning options
is the solid integration of
data flow as the data processor.
For example, for BigQuery,
you can use streaming Dataflow
to onboard data into BigQuery,
and then preprocess it
before it lands there.
Once the data is
in BigQuery, you
can train your
models using BQML,
email which is a variant of
SQL, and export between models
and use them inside of Dataflow
for streaming predictions.
For the Cloud AI
Platform, Dataflow
integrates with Kubeflow, which
is the orchestrator of machine
learning pipelines.
Cloud AI platform also
uses Dataflow internally
to do model training
on CPUs or GPUs.
For TensorFlow
Extended, Dataflow
enables all large scale
data processing, both
for feature processing as
well as for model improvement.
It can also bring
streaming events
into streaming inference.
Remember our motivating example
with the public safety agency?
Well, we worked with this
agency and created a solution
that is based on a time-series
anomaly detection solution
and is powered by Dataflow
and TensorFlow Extended.
This solution uses LSTM
encoder-decoder pattern,
and it reduced
the number of logs
that needed to be monitored
manually from billions per day
to just a few thousand
per day, which
is doable for their
analytical workforce.
This solution is now available
on the cloud.google.com
Dataflow in the
real-time AI section.
The solution consists
of three steps.
In the preprocessing
step, we convert log data
to a time-series TFRecord
formatted data set,
and we store it
in Cloud Storage.
Once data lands
in Cloud Storage,
we begin the model
training step.
Now for this, we use the Cloud
AI Platform Training API.
And this is where the
encoder-decoder LSTM
model gets created and stored
in the Cloud Storage again.
A parallel Dataflow
pipeline is running
and consumes this
LSTM model, and then
scores each incoming
data record,
creates both a reconstructed
and actual time-series,
compares the two, and flags
differences and anomalies.
The output is, again,
stored in Cloud Storage.
In our second
motivating example,
we also developed an
anomaly detection solution
which processes streaming
events, call records
for this telecom,
and the processing
is happening in Dataflow, and
the online inference is also
happening inside of Dataflow.
We use BigQuery ML to train
a K-means Cluster Model,
and we also use
Cloud to de-identify
and anonymize network
traffic records
before they are being
used for training.
Once the BQML model
is trained, it
gets deployed into
Streaming Dataflow,
and it's used for detecting
anomalies in real-time.
This solution is also
available on our website,
cloud.google.com/dataflow,
Real-time AI.
Here's a graph
that represents how
an anomaly gets detected using
a K-means cluster approach.
The solution finds
outliers by measuring
the distance between them and
the centers of the clusters.
Outliers that have a
distance of more than three
standard deviations
of the cluster
are considered anomalous.
This solution is also structured
into the three steps--
the feature preprocessing
step, the model training step,
and the anomaly reduction step.
In the feature
preprocessing step,
Dataflow is reading
data from Pub/Sub,
the call records, and is
using Cloud DLP to anonymize
the incoming records.
All call detail records
in an anonymous form
are stored in
BigQuery, and we use
BigQuery ML to train a model
that creates a K-means cluster
model.
This model is then used in a
parallel Dataflow pipeline,
which reads the same call
detail records and scores them
against the model.
The anomalies that are found
are outputted into Pub/Sub
for further action.
The solution is
available on our website
under the real-time section.
Feel free to discover
and customize.
In addition to the two existing
solutions that I just covered,
today, we are announcing new
components and new solutions.
We created, recently, new
Apache Beam components--
we call them transforms--
that integrate data flow
better with Cloud AI platform.
These components are
for video analysis,
for image analysis,
text analysis, DLP,
and many other areas.
We also created a
TFX component can
be embedded into Beam pipelines
for streaming predictions,
either on locally loaded
models or on remote models.
And the API stays the same.
In addition to the
new components,
we are also releasing today
five new solutions for anomaly
and pattern detection.
You can use these solutions
as is, you can customize them,
or you can use them as
examples for the components
that we developed
and provided for you.
Let's see what
these solutions do.
These solutions allow you to do
three types of things-- pattern
detection, anomaly detection,
and predictive forecasting.
For example, for
pattern detection,
you can find objects where
they're not supposed to be.
You can use our solutions
to anonymize and de-identify
operational data, a very
common need by users.
You can also use our
solutions to reduce shrinkage,
by tracking packages
door to door.
Those are just a few
examples of the application
of our solutions.
For anomaly detection
in the telecom case,
you can find malware by
detecting anomalies in traffic
between senders and recipients.
For financial services, you can
find anomalies in currency pair
and stock trades.
You can also find fraudulent
transactions or money transfers
in an account.
For predictive forecasting,
you can use our solutions
for equipment maintenance.
For example, you can forecast
the probability of equipment
failure based on
images, and then
send technicians to address
those forecasted failure
conditions.
Let's look at our
first solution.
The solution allows you to
detect patterns in video clips.
And here we integrated with the
Cloud Video Intelligence API
for object recognition.
As data gets-- as video clips
get stored in Cloud Storage,
we get a notification about
these clips through Pub/Sub
into Dataflow, and the clips
get uploaded into Dataflow
and processed through the
Video Intelligence API.
Once we know what objects are
inside of the video clips--
they can be cars, cats,
persons, or moving objects--
the labeling information
is stored together
with the clip metadata, either
into BigQuery or into Pub/Sub.
Dataflow here is used
for several things.
For example, we do
smart clip partitioning,
so that a one-minute
long clip gets
processed in just a few seconds.
Dataflow can also do smart
batching of video clips
to fully exhaust
your available quota
and increase your throughput.
You can use file inputs as
well as real-time inputs,
meaning Pub/Sub
messages, to indicate
that a new clip is available.
And information about labels can
be stored in data warehouses,
in file systems, or in
messaging [? boxes. ?]
This solution, as the
previous two solutions,
is available on
our website and can
be viewed in the Real-time AI
section on the Dataflow page.
In our second new
solution, we allowed
you to predict equipment
failure by using and analyzing
the images of this equipment.
Here, we integrated with
the Cloud Vision API,
and we looked for
patterns in images.
As data and as images get
uploaded to Cloud Storage,
notifications are
being sent to Dataflow.
Dataflow reacts to the
availability of new images
and calls the Cloud Vision API.
And once we have the
labels and classifications
of objects inside of images,
we store this information
in BigQuery.
You can use this
solution today as is,
or you can customize and
change the pipeline logic.
Because in addition
to the solutions,
we also give you the
standardized Apache Beam
transforms, which
you can integrate
in any kind of pipeline
you have to be.
You can also save costs through
Dataflow's smart batching
approach.
Dataflow is using its
State and Timer API
to convert a stream of image
files into micro batches
and calls the API,
the Cloud Vision API,
efficiently and fully exhausts
the quota and the capacity
that you have.
In our next solution,
we allowed customers
to anonymize and
de-identify PII data.
And here, we integrated
with Cloud DLP,
which is Google Cloud's service
for anonymizing private PII
data.
The service also
provides tokenization,
de-identification,
and other services.
Dataflow here is used to
maximize the throughput
of the Cloud DLP API.
Again, we're using the Dataflow
state and timer capabilities
to smartly batch together
calls to the Cloud DLP API
and use your
resources efficiently.
You can use file sources.
You can use real time sources.
And clean data can be stored in
a variety of outputs, including
BigQuery, Pub/Sub, Cloud
Storage, and other things.
This solution, as many others,
is available on our website.
Please navigate to
the Dataflow web page
and review the
real-time AI section.
In our next solution, we
implemented and integrated
with Cloud AI Prediction
API to find anomalies
in financial transactions.
This integration is
not just specific
to the financial
services industry.
You can use this pattern
across many, many industries.
Our particular model
to find anomalies
is based on BoostedTrees, so
it gives you another pattern
to put into your toolbox of
anomaly detection solutions.
The model was trained in
the Cloud AI Training API
and deployed and hosted into
the Cloud AI Prediction API.
Dataflow, as in
many other cases,
is used to optimize
performance and throughput.
It micro-batches
calls to Cloud AI,
and it increases the
throughput of your system.
In our last solution, we're
using yet another approach
for anomaly detection.
Here, we integrated
with TensorFlow Extended
and use the Run Inference
transform that was recently
developed and released.
This transform allows you
to have your models hosted
both inside of Dataflow, as
well as remotely in Cloud AI
Prediction.
Before we use Prediction
API, data actually
needs to be processed.
And here's where Dataflow's
strengths are coming to play.
Data gets onboarded-- raw data
from external data providers
gets onboarded through Pub/Sub.
And it gets aggregated
in Dataflow.
Specifically, we divide raw
trades into time windows
and run a variety of statistics
on them, for example,
calculate means,
candle statistics,
as well as the RSI stats, which
stands for Relative Strength
Index and is an indicator
of movement of data.
The preprocessed
data records get
transformed into TFX
[? sample ?] records
and stored in Cloud
Storage, from where
we pick up yet
another TFX pipeline
and use Cloud AI
Training to create
the model for the actual
anomaly detection.
This model is also based on
LSTM encoder-decoder approach.
It's trained in
Cloud AI Training,
and you can deploy
it in two places.
You can deploy it either
in Dataflow itself,
on the Dataflow workers
for local inference, which
reduces latency, or you
can deploy this model
in Cloud AI Prediction
API for remote inference.
The interface through these
calls is always the same.
This is where you can use
our newly developed TFX Run
Inference transform.
This solution, as
many others, is
available on the
Dataflow web page
under the real-time AI section.
Just to illustrate what Dataflow
does to preprocessed raw stock
trades before they get
used in the training
on the anomaly detection model,
take a look at this graph.
As raw events representing
trades enter the pipeline,
we divide them into time
windows, represented
by accumulators on
this graph, and we
calculate rolling windows
statistics on them.
For example, we calculate the
mean of these time windows,
and we calculate dependent
and other statistics,
for example, the RSI index.
Again, RSI stands for
Relative Strength Index.
With this, I would like
to wrap up my session
and just go through the
main points of the session.
As you've seen, you
can use Dataflow today
for data processing with a
variety of machine learning
technologies, including BigQuery
ML, Cloud AI, and TensorFlow
Extended.
We've recently
launched new Apache
Beam transforms for video,
images, DLP, and text
processing.
We also released a new TFX
transform that integrates
with Beam for generalized
streaming predictions.
And we launched and then
released five new solutions
for anomaly detection
and pattern recognition.
If you would like to
learn more, please go
to cloud.google.com/dataflow and
find the real-time AI section.
Thank you for
watching this session.
I hope you found it informative.
Till next time.